Welcome to another Famous Friday
where we look at famous entrepreneurs
and help you model their success to help your business grow.
Today’s lesson is Show Me.
If you have a new idea
a new concept, something that’s revolutionary
something that’s going to change the world
then you need to show me how it works.
Don’t just come to me with a piece of paper
or a PowerPoint file or an email
and say, “Here’s the blueprint, here’s how it’s going to work…”
Show me it’s working!
Because the bigger the idea is
the more unique it is, the newer it is
the more people are going to be skeptical that it’s going to work.
So instead of just trying to sell them with an email
or a PowerPoint presentation
sell them by actually showing them how your product or service works.
So one of my favorite examples is from Henry Ford.
Henry Ford, founder of the Ford Motor Company
legendary entrepreneur.
When he first started he was an engineer.
He was an engineer at Edison Electrical
and was helping create electricity for America.
And he wanted to do his own thing
you know, he wanted to be an entrepreneur.
He had ideas too. He didn’t want to just work for somebody else.
And so he wanted to get into the car business
and the car business was super new,
nobody was really making cars
a whole bunch of engineers just creating their own inventions.
And so he came up with his own invention
and he called it the Quadricycle.
And the quadricycle was basically two bicycles
that were attached together with a gasoline engine in the middle
and that was one of the very first cars in America
it was this primitive design.
And he wanted to get funding for this
and he wanted to quit his job and he wanted to go
and create a company building quadricycles.
And it was such a new, crazy idea, you know.
People are used to riding horses.
“Why would I ride this contraption quadricycle thing?”
And so instead of just going out and pitching people on…
with the perspectives on paper,
what he did was he built his first quadricycle.
And he wanted to go to William Murphy
who was a highly successful entrepreneur in the lumber business.
And when he went to pitch him he showed up in his quadricycle
a working quadricycle prototype unit
and he took William Murphy for a ride on it around town
and by the end of the ride they were in business together.
That’s how it works!
It’s so much easier to convince people to give you money
to buy from you
to refer people to you, to put you in the media
to have you be guest on their shows
whatever it is you’re looking for
it’s so much easier for people to understand what you do
when they can experience it
when you’re not just talking about it but they can feel it.
And so if you want to sell your idea, you want to get investors
you want to get customers
you want to get momentum then show me.
Make me feel it.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you like this video
you can support me by clicking on the link in the description.
Leave a comment. Let me know what you think.
And click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.